worked with at a young age already you
worked with obviously baslerman but also
Quentin Tarantino and Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood
's greater than I could have ever
imagined because he's all those things
that I thought he would be you know an
amazing filmmaker a Visionary and a
great leader and all those things but he
he was so fun well the first night that
we were filming we were doing the night
stuff where Leo comes and screams at us
in the car move this [__] piece of
[__] and we're doing this nice shooting
at one point Quentin he ordered a crepe
truck so uh so you they had Nutella and
strawberry crepes and that sort of thing
and it's three in the morning and you
know night shoots are usually this this
really exhausting thing but I just was
like a kid in a candy store I'm standing
next to Quinn and he goes how great is
this we're eating Crepes we're making a
movie he's like you know you know what
my thing is I want to give everybody on
my set such a good time that their next
job sucks
I thought like what what a great way to
make movies